why
so as we start with issue number two of
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe we
pick up with Trish he'll be who is a
news reporter covering the events as
they've unfolded since Deadpool had left
the compound of the Fantastic Four and
begun killing various superheroes and
supervillains now Trish he'll be in the
main earth-616 Universe is of course
still a reporter and also a romantic
interest for for Beast for Hank McCoy
and so this is Marvel telling us that in
this reality she pretty much plays the
same role and what she tells us is that
a multitude of villains and superheroes
have been killed by Deadpool which of
course include Doctor Doom and Howard
the Duck and of course because of the
fact that the x-men are counted among
those individuals who have been killed
she laments the fact that henkka that
hate McCoy is one of the people who have
died at this point we transition to New
York and we meet up with Deadpool as
he's a just confronting or fighting with
spider-man and of course spider-man is
doing what he can to hold off Deadpool
but again due to his healing factor
Deadpool is quite formidable and
Deadpool says that the whole reason why
he's here is for the purpose of killing
spider-man that again he's continuing
his role of killing various superheroes
and various supervillains due to the
fact that he's unleashed the part of
himself that is now a total murderer
and what spider-man says is that
multiple people have tried to kill him
before but a lot of the Psychopaths that
he's gone against have tried and they've
all failed and that Deadpool won't be
any different he also tells Deadpool
that he needs to watch out for the
asphalt because Deadpool is presumably
falling to his death at this point
Deadpool falls and smashes into a police
car and when he does of course a
gathering crowd along with spider-man
believes that it's possible he may be
dead but then Spiderman says that of
course is a good thing that Deadpool has
a healing factor which of course is what
allows Deadpool to heal from his
injuries and his Deadpool begins to come
to spider-man says that he's not the
kind of person to kill people but he's
not the kind of person that would kill
Deadpool and so he says that it's lucky
that that he is this kind of person
otherwise he would have killed Deadpool
for what it wasn't he's done and again
Deadpool maintaining this aspect of his
character the space on parody says that
the writers would not have allowed us
I demand a break his character and so
they wouldn't have allowed spider-man to
kill Deadpool anyway which of course is
again
Deadpool breaking the fourth wall and
relating to us as readers with regards
to how it is that writers write the
character of spider-man what we also see
spider-man saying is that he doesn't
want to hear any more nonsense from
Deadpool that he's had enough that
Deadpool's annoying him and again that
Deadpool is going to go down here that
Deadpool is going to be defeated but
what Deadpool says is that he's not here
that he's not going to cut spider-man
and instead what Deadpool does is put a
gun to the bottom of spider-man's head
and blow the top of his head off and so
of course Deadpool comments on this he
makes a joke about this and he makes a
reference to the spider-man No More
series and so on and again says that the
mistake the Psychopaths made was simply
just not shooting him with a gun which
would have been a much easier
alternative than trying to fight him in
hand-to-hand combat
at this point Deadpool makes his way he
leaves the scene and when he does again
the third voice the voice of the
psychopathic killer in his mind begins
to comment of course Deadpool says that
this was very fun and he says who's next
and the voice says it doesn't matter
who's next that as long as everybody
dies that's the only real objective is
the only real thing that matters from
here we of course see Deadpool
commenting and having this conversation
with himself where Deadpool says it
matters that he's doing all this that
he's killing these uh these smaller
people that he has bigger fish to fry
that he needs something much much larger
the the voice in his head says know says
that's the old Deadpool talking that he
doesn't need to impress anybody so long
as he's able to kill everyone but again
Deadpool is having this conflict and
says that no he wants it to be a much
bigger spectacle he wants to kill a much
more prominent group of people and so
what we do is we transition to the
Avengers headquarters and what we have
is the more against the more common
Avengers we have of course Spider Woman
Wolverine Hawkeye Luke Cage Captain
America Carol Danvers Thor and Tony
Stark and they're talking about
everything that's happened so far
they're talking about how Deadpool has
an effect killed a majority of the
superheroes which of course includes the
Avengers or a multitude of the Avengers
and that this group that we see here
appears to be the only group of the
Avengers left and there of course trying
to find out what it is that they're
going to do they're trying to come to a
decision and make up
and on what their course of action is
going to be but before they're able to
go too much further
Jarvis runs in and says that hank pym is
missing that hank pym is gone and of
course Tony Stark panics and is trying
to figure out what's taking place here
when Wolverine uses his sense of smell
and realizes that the Pym particles that
belong to Hank Pym are in the room and
that he's realized who it is a
Deadpool's going after and what we see
is that the massive weapons cache is I
guess in hand so it's grown back to its
regular size using Pym particles and of
course all these all these weapons and
armament explode which results in the
explosion of the Avengers mansion or the
Avengers Tower which of course leaves a
Wolverine almost totally destroyed as
well as the death of all the other
Avengers as well from here we see that
as Deadpool is making his way through as
he's making his way around that Luke
Cage emerges as one of the individuals
who has survived and Luke Cage says that
it would take a lot more than an
explosion to kill somebody with
unbreakable skin and Deadpool says he
had thought about that he thought about
that kind of problem for people that
were as strong as he was or as capable
as Luke Cage was and so what are you
done is he had taken Pym particles and
he had put him in the coffee that Luke
Cage was drinking and when Luke Cage
started to drink the coffee he of course
consumed the Pym particles and at this
point what Deadpool does is he uses the
helmet of Hank heme to expand the Pym
particles and in return kill Luke Cage
from here we of course see that that a
Thor arrives and Thor using the hammer
using Mjolnir goes on the offense
against Deadpool in an attempt to get
revenge on the death of the Avengers but
Deadpool says it again this is something
that he had considered and what he does
is using the Pym particles he kicks the
hell or kicks the hammer of Thor back at
Thor and then uses the uses the helmet
of ant-man to grow the hammer to a
massive size asking the question which
is stronger the hammer of Thor or Thor
skin and of course the hammer is able to
crush Thor entirely and of course Thor
is caught very off-guard by this he's
very surprised to realize that Deadpool
was able to kill him using his own head
he was he was surprised that Deadpool
was able to kill him using his own
hammer and what what Deadpool does is he
walks up
he walks up to the body of for any
squeezes he squeezes Thor's nose and
says boo but from here we transition
back to Deadpool again as he's having
this conversation with the the voice in
his head with a murderous side of
himself and this voice asks the question
are you satisfied and Deadpool of course
conversing with himself asked whether or
not he should be and the voice says no
the voice says that Deadpool should
never be satisfied until all the
superheroes are dead until everyone's
dead
and so what Deadpool does is continue
going on his onslaught going on his uh
his path of killing various superheroes
at this point we transition to two
Deadpool going against the Incredible
Hulk and again the Incredible Hulk is
able to physically tear the body of
Deadpool apart tearing him from limb
from limb
and of course ripping his head off The
Incredible Hulk goes on a rage saying
that that Deadpool had killed his
friends that he had killed the
incredible Hawks enemies and that he is
now an enemy of the Incredible Hulk Hulk
says that he's the only one that gets to
kill his enemies that Deadpool doesn't
doesn't have this right and so once the
once Deadpool is torn apart the
Incredible Hulk leaves it goes into a
cave and then goes back into his normal
form of Bruce Banner and it's at this
point that a Deadpool reconstitutes
himself from his head and uses a sword
to cut the head of a Bruce Banner off
effectively killing The Incredible Hulk
which of course is the question that
many people were asking of how it was
that did who would be able to kill the
Incredible Hulk in the first place and
so from here we again continue on this
road we continue with this story as we
see that on Mae and Mary Jane and
various other people who are friends of
x-men and Avengers and so on the people
who have been killed have come together
and the whole reason why they're meeting
is because they're pulling all the
resources together they're pulling all
their valuables whether it be money or
some form of jewelry or anything that
has any real value to it and they've
brought it to a table and the reason why
they've brought this to the table is
because they're hiring taskmaster and
they're hiring taskmaster for the
purpose of going after dead
pull and killing Deadpool with that
being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace